two seven seven two six
our american president's programming on
franklin d roosevelt continues
just ahead the president's first wartime
state of the union address delivered
january 6 1942
this footage is being shown courtesy of
the franklin d roosevelt library in hyde
park new york it runs about 40
on
minutes
6 1942
president roosevelt made his first
wartime state of the union address to an
audience composed of both houses of
congress the supreme court the
diplomatic corps and packed galleries
the traditional presidential motorcade
up pennsylvania avenue to capitol hill
is shown
and a few moments later the president is
seen entering the chamber of the house
of representatives to address congress
and the nation
members of the congress
it's my high privilege to present to you
the president of the united states
the vice president
mr speaker
members of the senate the house of
representatives of the united states
in fulfilling my duty
to report upon the state of the union
i am proud to say to you
that the spirit of the american people
was never higher than it is today
the union was never more closely knit
together
and this country
was never more deeply determined
to face the solemn tasks before it
the response of the american people has
been instantaneous
and it will be sustained
until
our security is ashore
one year ago today
i said to this congress
when the dictators are ready to make war
upon us they will not wait for an act of
war on our part
they
not we
will choose the time and the place and
the method of their attack
we now know
their choice of the time
a peaceful sunday morning
december 7th
1941
we know that choice of a place
an outpost an american outpost in the
pacific
we know their choice of the method
the method of hitler himself
japan's scheme of conquest goes back
half a century
it was not merely a policy of seeking
living room
it was a plan which included the
subjugation
of all the peoples in the far east and
in the islands of the pacific
and the domination of that ocean
by japanese military and naval control
of the western coasts
of north central and south america
the development of this ambitious
conspiracy
was marked
by the war against china
in 1894
the subsequent occupation of korea
the war against russia
in 1904
the illegal fortification of the
mandated pacific islands
following 1920
the seizure of manchuria in
1931 and the invasion of china in 1937
a similar policy of criminal conquest
was adopted by italy
the fascists first revealed their
imperial designs in libya and tripoli
in 1935 they seized abyssinia
their goal
was the domination of all north africa
egypt parts of france
and the entire mediterranean world
but the dreams of empire of the japanese
and fascist leaders
was modest in comparison
with the gargantuan aspirations of
hitler and his nazis
even before they came to power
in
1933 their plans for that conquest had
been drawn
they provided for ultimate domination
not of any one section of the world
but of the whole earth
and all the oceans on it
when
hitler
organized his berlin rome tokyo alliance
all these plans of conquest
became a single plan
under this in addition to our own
schemes of conquest japan's role
was obviously to cut off
our supply of weapons of war
to britain and russia and china
weapons which increasingly was speeding
the day of hitler's doom
the act of japan at pearl
harbor was intended to stun us
to terrify us
to such an extent that we would divert
our industrial and military strength to
the pacific area
or even
to our own continental defense
the plan
has failed in its purpose
we have not been stunned
we have not been terrified or confused
this very reassembling of the 77th
congress today
is proof of that
for the mood of quiet grim resolution
which here prevails
bodes ill
for those who conspired and collaborated
to murder world peace
and that mood is stronger
than any mere desire for revenge
it expresses the will of the american
people to make very certain
that the world
will never so suffer again
[Applause]
admittedly
we have been faced with hard choices
it was bitter for example not to be able
to relieve
the heroic and historic defenders of
wake island
it was bitter
for us not to be able to land
a million men
in a thousand ships in the philippine
islands
but this adds only to our determination
to see to it
that the stars and stripes will fly
again
over weight and guam
yes
see to it
but the brave people of the philippines
will be rid
of japanese imperialism and will live in
freedom and security and independence
powerful and offensive actions must and
will
be taken in proper time
the consolidation of the united nations
total war effort against our economy
enemies is being achieved
that
was and is
the purpose of conferences which have
been held during the past two weeks
in washington
and moscow
and trunking
that is the primary objective
of the declaration of solidarity signed
in washington on january 1st 1942
by 26 nations
against the axis power
difficult choices may have to be made in
the months to come
we do not shrink
from such decisions
we and those united with us will make
those decisions with courage and
determination
plans have been laid here and in the
other capitals
for coordinated and cooperative action
by all the united nations
military action and economic action
already we have established as you know
unified command of land sea and air
forces in the southwestern pacific
theater of war
there will be a continuation of
conferences and consultations among
military staffs
so that the plans and operations of each
will fit into the general strategy
designed to crush the enemy
we shall not fight isolated wars
each nation going its own way
these 26 nations are united not in
spirit and determination alone but in
the broad conduct of the war in all its
phases
for the first time since the japanese
and the fascists and the nazis started
along that blood-stained course of
conquest they now face the fact
that superior authorities are assembling
against them
gone forever are the days
when the aggressors could attack and
destroy their victims one by one
destroy them without unity of resistance
we as the united nations will so dispose
our forces
that we can strike at the common enemy
wherever the greatest damage can be done
the militarists
are berlin and tokyo started this war
but the masked angered forces of common
humanity will finish it
destruction
destruction of the milk material and
spiritual centers of civilization
this has been
and still is the purpose
of hitler and his italian and japanese
chess men
they would wreck the power of the
british commonwealth and of russia
and of china
and of the netherlands
and then combine all their forces to
achieve their ultimate goal the conquest
of the united states
they know that victory for us
means victory for freedom
they know that victory for us
means victory for the institution of
democracy
the ideal of the family the simple
principles of common decency and
humanity
they know that victory for us
means victory for religion
and they could not tolerate that
the world is too small
to provide adequate a living room
for both hitler
and god
[Applause]
in proof of that
the nazis have now announced their plan
for enforcing
their new
german pagan religion all over the world
the plan by which the holy bible and the
cross of mercy
would be displaced by mine camp
and the swastika and the naked sword
our own objectives are clear
the objective of smashing
the militarism imposed by warlords upon
their enslaved peoples
the objective of liberating the
subjugated nations
the objective of establishing and
securing
freedom of speech
freedom of religion
freedom from want
and freedom from fear
everywhere
in the world
we shall not stop short
of these objectives
nor shall we be satisfied merely to gain
them and then
call it a day
i know that i speak for the american
people
and i have good reason to believe that i
speak also for all the other peoples who
fight with us
when i say that this time
we are determined not only to win the
war but also
to maintain the security of the peace
that will follow
but we know that modern methods of
warfare make it a task not only of
shooting
and fighting
but an even more urgent one
of working and producing
victory requires the actual weapons of
war
and the means of transporting them
to a dozen points of combat
it will not be sufficient for us and the
other united nations
to produce a slightly superior supply of
munitions
to that of germany and japan and italy
and the stolen industries and the
countries which they have overrun
the superiority of the united nations in
munitions and ships
must be overwhelming
so overwhelming the axis nations can
never hope to catch up with it
and so in order to attain this
overwhelming superiority
the united states must build planes and
tanks and guns and ships
to the utmost limit of our national
capacity we have the ability and
capacity to produce arms
not only for our own forces but also
for the armies navies and air forces
fighting on our side
and
our overwhelming superiority of armament
must be adequate to put weapons of war
at the proper time
into the hands of those men in the
conquered nations
who stand ready to seize the first
opportunity to revolt against their
german and japanese oppressors and
against against the traitors in their
own ranks
known by the already infamous name of
whistling
and i think
that it is a fair prophecy
to say that as we get guns to the
patriots in those lands
they too
will fire shots heard around the world
this production of ours in the united
states must be raised far above present
levels
even though it will mean the dislocation
of the lives and occupations of millions
of our own people
we must raise our sights all along the
production line
let no man say it cannot be done
it must be done and we have undertaken
to do it
i have just sent
a letter of directive
to the appropriate departments and
agencies of our government
ordering that immediate steps be taken
first to increase our production rate of
airplanes
so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall produce 60 thousand planes
ten thousand
ten thousand by the way more than the
goal
that we set a year and a half ago
this includes 45 000 combat planes
bombers dive bombers pursuit plants
the rate of increase
will be maintained
continued
so that next year 1943
we shall produce a hundred and
twenty-five thousand airplanes including
a hundred thousand combat plans
[Applause]
second
to increase our production rate of tanks
so rapidly that in this year 1942
we shall produce 45 000 tanks
and to continue that increase so that
next year 1940
we shall produce 75 000 tanks
third
to increase our production rate of
anti-aircraft guns
so rapidly that in this year 1942 we
shall produce 20 000 of them
and to continue that increase so that
next year
1943 we shall produce 35 000
anti-aircraft guns
and fought
to increase our production rate of
merchant ships
so rapidly that in this year 1942 we
shall build
eight
million dead weight tons
as compared with a 1941
completed production of one million one
hundred thousand
[Applause]
and finally we shall continue that
increase
so that next year
1943 we shall build 10 million tons of
shipping
these figures
and similar figures for a multitude of
other implements of war
will give the japanese and the nazis
a little idea
of just what they accomplished in the
attack at pearl harbor
and i rather hope
that all these figures which i have
given
will become common knowledge
in germany and japan
our task is hard
our task is unprecedented and the time
is short
we must train every existing
armament-producing facility to the
utmost
we must convert every available plant
and tool to war production
that goes all the way
from the greatest plants to the smallest
from the huge automobile industry to the
village machine shop
production for war is based on men and
women
the human hands and brains which
collectively we call labor
our workers stand ready to work long
hours
to turn out more in a day's work
to keep the wheels turning and the fires
burning
24 hours a day and seven days a week
they realize well that on the speed and
efficiency of their work
depend the lives of their sons and their
brothers on the fighting front
production for war is based on metals
and raw materials
steel copper
rubber
aluminum zinc
tin
greater and greater quantities of them
will have to be diverted to war purposes
civilian use of them will have to be cut
further and still further
and in many cases completely eliminated
war costs money
so far we've hardly even begun
to pay for it
we've devoted only 15 of our national
income to national defense
as will appear
in my budget message tomorrow
our war program for the coming fiscal
year
will cost
56
billion
or in other words
more than half of the estimated annual
national income
that means
taxes
and bonds
and bonds and taxes
it means cutting luxuries and other
non-essential
in a word it means an all-out war by
individual effort
and family effort in a united country
only this all-out scale of production
will hasten the ultimate all-out victory
speed will come
lost ground
can always be regained
lost time
never
speed will save lives speed will save
this nation which is in peril
speed
will save our freedom and our
civilization
and slowness
well it has never been
an american characteristic
as the united states goes into its full
stride
we must always be on guard
on god against
misconceptions
which will arise some of them naturally
or which will be planted among us by our
enemies
we must guard against complacency
we must not underrate the enemy
he is powerful and cunning
and cruel
and ruthless
he will stop at nothing
that gives him a chance to kill
and to destroy
he has trained his people
to believe that their highest protection
is achieved by waging war
for many years he has prepared for this
very conflict
planning and plotting and training
and arming and fighting
we have already tasted defeat
we may suffer further setbacks
we must face the fact of a hard war a
long war
a bloody war
a costly war
we must on the other hand
guard against defeatism
that
has been one of the chief weapons of
hitler's propaganda machine
used time and again with deadly results
it will not be used successfully on the
american people
we must guard against divisions among
ourselves and among all the other united
nations
we must be particularly vigilant against
racial discrimination in any of its ugly
forms
hitler will try again to breed mistrust
and suspicion between one individual and
another one group one another one race
in another one government and another
he will try to use the same technique of
falsehood and rumor mongering
with which he divided france from
britain
he is trying to do this even now
but he will find a unity
a unity of will and purpose against him
which will persevere
until the destruction of all his black
designs upon the freedom and people of
the world are entered
we cannot wage this war in the defensive
spirit
as our power and our resources are fully
mobilized
we shall carry the attack
against the enemy
we shall hit him
and hit him again
wherever and whenever we can reach him
we must keep him far from our shores
for we intend to bring this battle to
him
on his own home grounds
[Applause]
american armed forces
must be used at any place in all the
world
where it seems advisable to engage the
forces of the enemy
in some cases these operations will be
defensive in order to protect key
positions
in other cases these operations will be
offensive
in order to strike at the common enemy
with a view to his complete encirclement
and eventual total defeat
american armed forces will operate at
many points in the far east
american armed forces will be on all the
oceans
helping to guard the essential
communications which are vital to the
united nations
american land and air and sea forces
will take stations in the british isles
which constitute an essential portrait
in this great world struggle
[Applause]
american armed forces will help to
protect this hemisphere
and help also to protect bases outside
this hemisphere
which could be used for an attack
on the america
if any of our enemies from europe or
from asia
attempt long-range rage
by suicide squadrons of bombing planes
they will do so only in the hope of
terrorizing our people and disrupting
our morale
our people are not afraid of that
we know that we may have to pay a heavy
price
for freedom
we will pay
this price
with a will
whatever the price
[Applause]
it is a thousand times worth
no matter what our enemies
in their desperation may attempt to do
to us
we will say as the people of london have
said we can take it
and what's more
what's more
we can give it back
and we will give it back with compound
interest
[Applause]
when our enemies challenged our country
to stand up and fight
they challenge each and every one of us
and each and every one of us
has accepted the challenge
for himself
and for his nation
there are only some
there were only some 400 united states
marines
who in the heroic and historic defense
of wake island
inflicted
such great losses on the enemy
some of those men were killed in action
and others are now prisoners of war
when the survivors of that great fight
are liberated and restored to their
homes
they will learn that
130 million of their fellow citizens
have been inspired
to render their own full share
of service and sacrifice
we can well say that our men
on the fighting fronts have already
proved
that americans today are just as rugged
and just as tough as any of the heroes
whose exploits we celebrate on the 4th
of july
[Applause]
many people ask
when will this war end
there's only one answer to that
it will end just as soon as we make it
end
by our combined efforts our combined
strength
our combined determination to fight
through and work through until the end
the end
of militarism
in germany
and italy and japan
[Applause]
most certainly
we shall not settle for less
that is the spirit in which discussions
have been conducted during the visit
of the british prime minister to
washington
mr churchill and i
understand each other
our motives
and our purposes
together during the past two weeks we
have faced squarely
the major military and economic problems
of this greatest world war
all in our nation
have been cheered
by mr churchill's visit
we have been deeply stirred
by his great message to us
he is welcome in our midst
now
and in days to come
and we unite in wishing him
a safe return
to his home
[Applause]
for we are fighting on the same side
with the british people
who fought alone
for long terrible months
and withstood the enemy with fortitude
and tenacity and skill
we are fighting on the same side
with the russian people
who have seen the nazi horde swarm up to
the very gates of moscow
and who with almost superhuman will
and courage
have forced the invaders back into
retreat
[Applause]
we are fighting on the same side as the
brave people of china
those millions who for four and a half
long years
have withstood bombs and starvation
and equipped the invaders time and again
in spite of the superior japanese
equipment and arms
yes we are fighting
on the same side
as the indomitable dutch
we are fighting on the same side
as all the other governments in exile
whom hitler and all his armies
and all his gestapo have not been able
to conquer
but we
of the united nations
are not making all this sacrifice of
human effort and human lives
to return to the kind of world we had
after the last world war
we are fighting today for security
for progress
and for peace
not only for ourselves but for all men
not only for one generation but for all
generations
we are fighting to cleanse the world
of ancient evils
ancient ills
our enemies are guided
by brutal cynicism
by unholy contempt
for the human race
we
are inspired by a faith
that goes back through all the years to
the first chapter of the book of genesis
god created man
in his own image
we on our side are striving to be cruel
to that divine heritage
we are fighting as our father's about
to uphold the doctrine that all men are
equal in the sight of god
those on the other side
are striving to destroy
this deep belief
and to create a world
in their own image
a world of tyranny
and cruelty
and certain
that is the conflict the day and night
now pervades our lives
no compromise can end that conflict
the never has been the never can be
successful compromise between good and
evil
only
only total victory
can reward
the champions of tolerance
and decency
and freedom
and faith
[Applause]
now more on franklin d roosevelt with a
look at the little white house in warm
springs georgia where roosevelt spent
much of his time away from the white
house
it lasts just under 25 minutes
[Music]